la justice est toujours la diaspora
libanaise a soif de justice et souvenirs
du 4 ou de melgven ils sont toujours
aussi douloureux cette richesse est
dommage qu'un pays aussi beau que le
liban sauf autant
la déflagration est à glacer le sang
plus de 200 libanais meurt dans
l'explosion aux abords du port de
beyrouth plus de 6000 personnes sont
blessées les enquêtes sting et n'ont
toujours pas apporté les réponses
attendues ce qui m'attriste le plus
c'est que après deux ans toutes les
enquêtes
qui ont été faites au pas fait mon
abouti à rien où on sait même pas qui
est le coupable
on fait rien l'ondé de choc en plus de
faucher des vies humaines a du même
souffle balayé le poumon économique du
pays c'est une descente aux enfers
presque littéralement la pauvreté c'est
vraiment élargie jusqu'à toucher à la
hauteur de 80% de la population
libanaise la monnaie nationale est en
chute libre et l'inflation de certaines
denrées de base atteint les 40% les
libanais font face à des pénuries de
médicaments les interruptions de courant
ponctuent le quotidien des gens qui sont
tous des enfants tristes toufik hamzé 26
ans est lui-même résigner à fuir son
pays l'an dernier il laisse derrière lui
la pâtisserie qu'il avait fondée à fait
de poursuivre des études en génie à
montréal tu peux pas rester dans un pays
qui est comme ça dans ce pays que tu
sais pas qu'est ce qui ne va pas c'est
demain même si tu as des plans à faire
un meilleur vivre pourtant payé pour ta
famille pour comme lui ils seraient plus
de 300000 libanais avoir quitté en deux
ans en quête d'une vie meilleure à cette
cadence là c'est quelque chose vraiment
qui est apparent parce que ça pour les
faire saigner le pays de sa force de
genest est ce que vous comptez retourner
vivre aux images enfin pour moi pas plus
tard que cette semaine ainsi le grain
s'est effondré dans le port de beyrouth
signe que nouvel accident n'est jamais
bien loin le deuxième anniversaire de la
tragédie sert de devoir de mémoire
essayer le plus possible
de garder cet événement donc vivant dans
notre mémoire dans notre conscience pour
pour affecter un changement
c'est en se serrant les coudes que la
diaspora traverse lentement cette crise
qui semble aujourd'hui s'enliser ici
jean philippe use radio canada montréal